well how the world's first comprehensive
climate change agreement was reached in
Paris yesterday it's been hailed by
President Obama and others is the best
chance we have to save the planet the
core of the deal is legally binding
committing nearly 200 countries who took
part to take action to address global
warming and climate change where I'm
joined now from Hull by John Prescott
law passed between the Deputy Prime
Minister of course an out chair of the
Council of Europe's Environment
Committee he was these negotiator on the
Kyoto Protocol in 1997 very good morning
to you
Lord Prescott and and tell me then
mentioning 1997 how does this Agreement
build on the groundwork you and others
achieved back then well this is a
remarkable deal but to compare it to
Kyoto
I was only negotiated for the 40
industrial countries and America were
with us
it's only when President Bush came in
that he took out of the agreement so it
was a smaller con but it did recognize
their recognized
carbon climate change and temperature
that is now gone in the last 20 years to
this new deal it is a remarkable deal it
is global it accepts the science and I
met with the French Minister and Tony
and mattered for with the French
Minister and indeed Miliband and we gave
him this report we hope to work with him
of Buda won the election and all the
points in this 12 major points and now
in this new agreement so I'm quite
pleased with it it recognizes the
science it sets a target in as a legal
framework it recognizes we must switch
from oil and coal and now into the
renewables that was embodied in this
agreement so of course we must say I
only pity we've been there in the
negotiations
well of course labor and not so leading
the negotiations for the UK what do you
make then of the UK's commitment to all
this I mean as a fully industrialised
country will it be an example in
particular to the developing world yet
domestically we see things like
subsidies to some renewables being cut
yes well this is an important point you
had to get an agreement between the
developing countries under rich
countries we didn't have to
without Kyoto it was only the rich
countries now you have to have a global
agreement they've all signed up for it
but do bear in mind if you notice there
wasn't a boat on this one there wasn't a
boat that the Kyoto you have to then
begin to put it into a protocol and then
you have to sign up for it and we'll see
what happens then
unfortunately this government has moved
away from the main recommendations it's
reducing the subsidies for renewable
which the conference says you must talk
to and give up some of the coal and it's
given to the oil industry that we're
trying to move away from an economy on
fuel on oil on coal but India and China
are still going to do some of that
so there are difficult things to come
and that's why and Britain we brought in
the climate change act no other
countries got that act with an
independent review so I welcome the
review in the beginning but the next
stage must be now to strengthen
parliamentarians to make sure when they
ratify the agreement when it comes to be
occupied by national parliaments that
the government's carry out their promise
will move into a new stage now everybody
should have a climate change
committed legally in every country and
enforced by the backbenchers what do you
think I mean with the UK's climate
change Act as you mentioned there from
2008 that this government's may not hit
the targets or indeed there is provision
for the secretary of state to vary the
targets know what it has to do under the
legislation you're required to come back
to Parliament to repeal it they tried to
do that in Australia but the government
didn't have a majority the real problem
is of what they were telling me in Paris
the government's going in the opposite
direction it's giving subsidy to the oil
industries and removing it from the
removable from the renewables it's
actually will scrapped the zero control
on housing well it for the insulation
and that is another aunt it's got rid of
the carbon storage Act just recently
during the time of the conference
everything on carbon they say is value
for money what the conference is saying
we must make a fundamental change about
saving the planet
not necessarily saving the money which
seems to be herbs
obsession of this government yeah well
you talk there Lord Prescott about time
I know you please if you look at all the
evidence it shows you're on energy
changes you can save a lot more money
for example when we brought in the
climate change Act we brought in a
climate levee and we put that onto the
industry the industry said that was
wrong to begin with but then they found
they weren't using energy efficiently
enough and they made money on it so that
was something that was agreed between
the private sector and the government
not posed by legislation but by the
sheer sense that it was more efficient
more effective you saved on carbon and
you make more money we've got to move to
a green economy ok well you're clearly
of the view that Britain's commitment to
dealing with greenhouse gas emissions
would be safer under a Labour government
but of course the prospect of that
happening under jeremy corbyn's
leadership still seem to be very far
away the attacks just keep coming one of
the very latest from tony blair calling
them a tragedy well everyone tired to
review a lot of people vote to put
Jeremy is the leader and he's the one
that's leading is that the month
interesting each supports the climate
change the Tories don't really they want
to undermine what we did but at the end
of the day the party is sorted out he's
only being in a few months for goodness
sake let us keep going an awful lot of
people to support him and we'll get on
with getting the policy concentrated I
know that the press are obsessed with
Jeremy well they've always been cest
with Labour leadership whoever it was
let's get on with the job and give him a
chance for God's sake but it's about a
United Labour Party isn't it and there's
all this talk of Jeremy Corbyn now
having won Oldham and
and given that free voter on Syria
recasting the party that the front bench
team more in his own image do you think
that would be a wise way to approach the
future well I've been in the parliament
for 40 odd years I've seen a number of
leaders come along and they change it as
they think what Jeremy seems to be
saying I want the party more involved in
it well that's an argument for us to
have as the leader he has earned the
right democratically to lead the party
what we now is go through the process
but there are some people in the party
who I call the bitter right
want to continue the war that they lost
the party has spoken we have the leader
and he has to recognize being a leader
perhaps more than representing a protest
movement either way he's a different man
isn't he
either way quite a people seem to be
saying we want him there but at the end
of the day Jeremy will have to decide
there is a balance between what is the
leadership of the Labour Party and
representing that a very difficult job
and the one of having to carry out
commitments they stopped the war he's
been in that Oliver years do you just
want him to say sorry I'm not going to
do it it's only a few MPs demanding that
by the way not all the MPs
he's keeping to what he thinks are his
principles and I have to say the elected
did seem to like to have a politician
who still continued to do what he
believed it that's the difficult balance
for Jeremy nearly have to carry that out
I'm also reading not sure if it's true
in my Sunday papers in one of them
anyway that he might try to put Ken
Livingstone into the House of Lords Lord
Livingstone that would be a bigger turn
up for the books and you ending up there
nothing's a surprised with Livingstone
is it I mean I'd be on the executive
when I had to vote for him and hold my
nose because he didn't want to carry out
the party's policy that Ken Livingstone
and that's John Prescott thank you very
much indeed Lord Prescott very good to
talk to you okay